ja albert einstein ist zurück kommt mir
auch schon von hinten bekannt vor und
damit herzlich willkommen heute meine
lieben freunde zu einer neuen episode
brainard ihr seht schon das hier ist das
erste rätsel um das wir uns heute
kümmern müssen und zwar erfüllst du dir
einen traum
das war schon mal nicht ich weiß nicht
genau was wir machen müssen auf der uss
auch nicht ja auch nicht wir können
vielleicht irgendwie müssen die locker
reiben reise um die welt es gibt eine
hütte am see erfüllt den traum es gibt
eine hütte am see alles klar oder
beherrsche mehrere sprachen nämlich
würde sagen reise um die welt und
beherrscht mehrere sprachen auch und es
gibt ordnete am see es waren darin jetzt
falsch drei wochen später
[Musik]
erstens rätsel ich brauch direkten tipp3
wird die lampe des aladins mehrmals und
tippe dann auf das buch wissen ist macht
ich hasse es jetzt schon wieder nächstes
rätsel welche geometrische form hat die
meisten seiten also 1 234 hat das linke
der hier ist ein kreis 0 oder unendlich
viele seiten
das ist die frage es kommt halt auf den
kreis an als ich mal nochmals wen
würdest du retten deine mutter oder
deine freundin warum nochmals wir hatten
noch nie so ein rätsel
meine mutter ich habe keine freude
aber meine freundin auch falsch ich
selbst nicht es ist krieg nicht in
heimen oder ganz auf draufdrücken dass
die blase zerplatzt nähe geht auch nicht
ihm wie kleiner ziehen größer ziehen
gedrückthalten umdrehen
ich brauche tipp 1 wach auf also wir
müssen irgendwie aufwachen ja bruder
er wacht doch nicht auf gedrückt halten
zur seite ziehen kann so wie sie soll
dann schüttet jetzt ist mich sogar das
spiel hier schon säcke das kleine ferkel
auf also einfach drauf tipi weckt das
natürlich nicht auf dass er auf diese
einfach hier am schwanz ziehen nur homo
geht natürlich auch nicht hier dass
diese drei buchstaben diese zeit weg
nähe der schmetterlinge auf dem 2000
jahre später ich habe keinen plan wie
das ganze passieren sollen
ich habe den schmetterling schon überall
draufgezogen muss ich die ohren
hochziehen nehmen irgendwas haben es um
doppeltops schweinchen irgendwie
schütteln es geht gar nichts von daher
also wir haben jetzt einen tipp von mir
klick ich mal draufhalten seine nase
gedrückt bis es aufwacht
[Applaus]
hilft ihnen ein erfolgreiches blind date
zu haben also wenn er den diamanten auf
ihnen das ist falsch auf die frau das
ist falsch das haus auf ihn ist falsch
das ist falsch machen hier mal da falsch
machen hier falsch da die haben ein haus
falsche kate jede kombination ist falsch
nehmen wir den dass das ich habe jetzt
wieder
ich habe jetzt schon wieder keinen plan
mehr ich habe aber noch nie nen welt
kann der letzte gar nicht so viel zu
sagen
klicken wir jetzt mal unten auf die
glühbirnen und seen clique den hund
mehrmals an nötig es ist so dumm und
stumpf und ich bin auch ziemlich dumm
finde die nummer acht ist jetzt
angezeigt dort wird so einfach finden
ich nochmal achten muss ich das ist auch
jetzt nicht wahr
ich bin ja alles durchgegangen
hier ist keine acht
hier ist keine acht ich habe die
vermutung dass die das extra wollen dass
man keine acht findet dass man sich
deswegen die werbung anschaut einen tipp
bekommt und dann zeigt er plötzlich die
acht an von 1 mach ich jetzt mal ein
screenshot und wir vergleichen das
gleich und ich denke jetzt auf die
glühbirne und dort stehen dass sich dort
die acht befinden soll wenn ich sehe
dass die acht da sieht man die handhabe
ich blende euch jetzt mal den screenshot
ein ja die acht war schon die ganze zeit
dort und ich sollte echt mal eine brille
nachdenken machen wir nun allerdings
weiter mit dem rätsel nummer 60 finde
das grün das hier ist falsch das ist
falsch das ist falsch natürlich auch
moment ach so
so finde das sechseck ja super kann ich
da theoretisch einfach so machen und
dann solche sachen ärgern stärke von mir
was kommt nach bfd
[Musik]
was kommt danach
bfc dann von buchstaben später ist geh
wieder b dann haben wir die ffg
[Musik]
[Applaus]
verrückter nadel kreis ich glaube wir
müssen auch so wir müssen alle
teilbereiche das irgendwann dreht sich
das ding oder wie ich muss kurz meinen
jetzt habe ich meine super manpower
uniform an also jetzt kann ich wirklich
gar nichts mehr schief gehen mit den
rätseln vorne machen wir weiter mit nur
64 auf welche zahl wird der
stundenzeiger nach drei stunden zeigen
der stundenzeiger wird auf 1 auf 1
[Musik]
natürlich sofort um als bei umgefallen
oder was 0 oder oder bistum nach drei
stunden
es ist 10 11 12 uhr der stundenzeiger
wird auf 110 oder auf 2
[Musik]
[Applaus]
rätsel nummer fünf
wie viele küken gibt es können wir
bejahen können sie natürlich wiederum
ziehen dass er wieder wahnsinn
wir haben 123456 küche haben wir es ist
11 sorry wir haben in einer wohnung im
keller auch noch sieben küken versteckt
größte meinen hund ist das nächste
rätsel der knochen ist es natürlich
nicht wenn die knochen nehmen auf ihn
drauf ist natürlich auch nicht so wenn
wir den hier irgendwie dann irgendwie
auf den gedrückthalten nähe und
irgendwie hier den hey wir packen da so
einen knochen hin aber der ist
eigentlich komplett egal fürs rätsel
allerdings machen die als auch schon
weiter mit rätseln nummer 67 finde die
versteckten sterne also wir können hier
nicht so herum ziehen wir können
nirgendwo draufklicken also können wir
was ist falsch wir können hier das küken
schreiben hier den fuchs mal reiben hier
die hasen finde die versteckten sterne
etwas kleiner zeh irgendwas rütteln
[Applaus]
ich sag dir das ist das outfit bruder
sie sind eine einheit
wir sind da kommt akkordeon wie der
franzose sagt das ist ein richtiges
rätsel wo dann beim familien dinner so
der coole single onkel mit um die ecke
kommt genau ich habe hier acht
streichelzoo guck mal wenn ich einen
verschiebe was ist dann gleich genau
also mache die gleichung war wir können
hier was rüberziehen das geht nicht das
geht auch nicht wir das hier geht auch
nicht sehen gleich nee das geht nicht
13 13 gleich dass das was ändert absolut
garnichts verschiebe die ersten
streichhölzern klammern 1 nach links und
verschiebe auch das minus von 80 die
erklärung verstehe ich nicht machen
addiere im folgenden die drei größten
zahlen
die drei größten zahlen
es ist 5 6 und 3 bis zum 14
addiere im folgenden die drei größten
zahlen
wir haben 99 und 9
das sind 27 drei größten zeit oder es
geht um die 70 oben wenn man 70 plus
durch millionäre also ich bin gespannt
was uns der tipp jetzt hier sagt nimm
auch die zahlen auf der tastatur 7 plus
ab das war nochmal reden dann sagst du
doch mal jede zahl nur einmal benutzen
da 7 + 18 15 plus 924 wenn das es ist
richtig ich habe da kein pardon
ja
das ist so wie das ist so wie wie krieg
ist das braucht keiner will keiner
und immer mag auch keiner so wie mich
mich mag auch keiner an der stelle mich
dass heute videos allerdings auch wenn
meine lieben freunde wird euch der
mittlerweile schon dritte teil von
brainard gefallen hat das gern einen
daumen hoch oder dem video das schreibt
immer und in die kommentare auf den
vierten teil hätte und jetzt befinden
wir uns im auto findet ihr oben einen 23
gelände wieder darauf könnt ihr einen
kanal kostenlos abonniert und er
verpasst keine videos mehr wenn ich
schon aber nicht gern auf die glocke
dann kommt nämlich direkt eine
benachrichtigung wenn ich ein neues
video hochladen und hier ist ein video
verlinkt das soeben auf eine zweite
kanal online gegangen ist habe ich
nämlich das erste youtube video
angeschaut